in the effective handling of men whose
wounds are of the mind and spirit
the battalion Medical Officers position
is unique he is a part of the outfit he
lives the life he intimately understands
the stresses he is an officer and yet a
physician if he establishes a reputation
for fairness and consistency his word
will be heeded his explanations and
reassurances accepted his encouragement
of the man in coping with his fears
resentments and briefs can provide
stronger psychological support than any
other medical officer in the division
there is not much the individual
battalion medical officer can do to keep
men from injury in battle there is much
he can do to prevent important loss of
manpower from psychiatric cross
that first day I wasn't thinking much
about my contribution to the prevention
of any casualties except perhaps myself
I was uneasy I didn't know what to
expect look doc there's your time
I take it you're dr. Jung that's right
glad to see you again your relief
my name
Berlin
yeah does move the store for some
he's dropped his gear here doctor all of
the comments take care of it okay let's
go meet the old man I'd heard about
Peters he was a good battalion medical
officer no not a psychiatrist he seemed
to have been quite sold on the subject
Abbott
dr. Yost he reported in the division and
just got here
Oh doc or berlin's replacement huh yes
glad to have you aboard you're getting
into one of the best outfits on the line
it's a major part in my exec glad to
meet you got a good bunch of men here
doctor I guess I thought a CEO and an
exec and combat would be rather taught
and brass-bound but these men and in
fact most of the officers I was to meet
I learned to respect for many reasons
they were top professional soldiers
highly competent and assured but
friendly and receptive to any sensible
ideas we had to offer yeah the other day
we were talking about this combat
fatigue problem and the surger says to
me without baton and I colonel there's a
direct relation between the quality of
leadership and the number of NP
casualties in any battalion first I knew
that there was nothing personal in it as
a matter of fact I I agree with him
completely although I never looked at it
in those terms before he wants more he's
been keeping a lot of man we thought I'd
gone psycho I mean in T case and
returning them to the line
yeah the old professor showed us at some
of these Marines that looked like they
couldn't take it were a really good
stuff it's surprising what a night's
sleep a little encouragement and getting
them back pronto will do for most of
them well we'll see you colonel right oh
by the way surge able company may have
some rough going tomorrow they lead the
attack jump off at 0 6:30 thanks major
the words out we'll probably have a few
extra customers at City Hall tonight
well you know how to handle the search
yeah before dark Peter's joined the
battalion sick bay unloaded too many
good men to the rear he can probably
give you some good pointers on this
stuff and we need all the men we can
well glad to have you with us thank you
sit Thanks
come on so this is it yep
say why all the emphasis on NP
casualties
how about Marines were rugged they are
more than most but any man can develop
symptoms that make him temporarily or in
a few cases even permanently ineffective
in combat the old man knows that he's
pretty much on the ball with this
problem and that helps
hi doc hi Andrews are you finding
here comes the adjutant
I joined his doctor Yost McKenna nice
been our adjutant doctor how do you do
sergeant major Duffield primary doctor
sorry do that dr. Oberlin was glad to
see you
he's been grassing about rotation for a
long time expect waiting for me was
beginning to get him down because so by
the way sergeant major took care of that
kid you sent in one it was all shook up
yeah thanks a lot just so I'm scooting
out of here well you said we can all use
an extra hand around the CP after you
sort of convinced us well Sean that's
all it took for most of them I didn't
realize it at first but the sergeant
major and the adjutant gave us some
wonderful help sometimes I couldn't
decide what to do with a man a couple of
days around the CP gave me a chance to
keep my eye on him most of them went
back to duty on their own when they were
rested son needed a little encouragement
many men were kept at duty who would
have been lost to the rear we had to be
careful not to clog up the CP or have
sick bay no one is an easy out from duty
we've gotta have cooperation from the
line officers I never miss a chance to
keep them informed of medical problems
concerning their men and getting their
angle on them particularly NP cases it
pays off incidentally what's all this
about dr. Oberlin
it was a hard charger and a damn good
doctor but lately the job seemed to be
getting him down he was getting a bit
Moody and let it influence the handling
of his patients what do you mean
sometimes it evacuate everybody and
sometimes he wouldn't evacuate anyone I
don't get you sometimes it almost seemed
to be if I can't get out nobody will
attitude none other times it was if I
can't get out at least you can I'm sure
I didn't think it out that way but it's
one of those things you get a watch in
yourself
getting used to it after a while nobody
likes his stuff but it does become
tolerable how about some chow oh yeah I
wasn't very hungry and I didn't
understand yet that this was one of
those opportunities Peters had spoken I
was meeting some of the company officers
for the first time few of them were down
from briefing and it stopped by the mess
area before going back to their men any
marine officers come out with you doctor
I was corrected my relief any minute now
no sorry
quit kidding yourself milk you relief
just graduated from grade school how the
women making out in the states these
days do they miss me oh they sure do you
still got one of my boys the one of the
sprained ankle how's he doing
we've had him sitting around the supply
tent making out forms another few days
and he'll be good as new what about that
feller I sent down to drizzly runs we
cooked him up it's probably more of an
emotional thing than infectious another
48 hours around the CP and he'll be okay
you better keep your eye on him though
I'm not sure he can take much more oh
why not evacuate him we've got fighting
to do up here the cool jack anybody can
get a belly full some sooner than others
so what he won't be any good to you even
if you do get him back on the line
wait a minute Pete send us back plenty
of man I never thought we'd see again
they perform to that sold me the
equivalent of a couple of platoons of
CEO said makes a hell of a lot of
difference I haven't noticed too many of
these characters returning to my platoon
maybe there's a reason hey Pete what
percentage would you say of all our
casualties are sent back to your
division psychiatrist it depends on the
situation in heavy prolong combat and
where we're getting crowded or have to
move out quick maybe one out of six or
seven wounded well suppose you have the
time in space depends practically all of
the men who were stuck even before they
get into the battle or sent back to duty
promptly those men who do break in
battle and need a little more time we
hold for a day or two most of these men
get back on the lines too
what about the division psychiatrist
they send back well over happens and
then we do have to evacuate yeah but how
many of them only crap out again believe
it or not only a very small percentage
see what I mean look after competition
doctor seems like we're all turning into
a bunch of psychiatrists you know that's
very interesting because whether you
realize it or not you hit it right on
the head the tune leaders can be our
biggest help in this whole problem hell
I'm not trying to be a chowderhead about
this thing I'm open-minded and only
slightly [ __ ] anybody who's been out
here long enough is likely to notice
some changes in himself goes off his
feet a bit it's a little sour irritable
how long have you been out here Jack
okay okay time for sick call look why
don't you get squared away and I'll see
you there finish your coffee though
okay Oh doc what about that ammo carrier
I sent down to the weeps one who said he
got pooped out carrying Emma on the hill
it looked kind of shook Murphy yeah I
thought he was genuine enough not a very
rugged time for better mature we gave
him a little rest in a pep talk told him
you might be able to make him a rifleman
okay doc thanks for the referral thanks
for the referral
lines seem to have picked up the lingo
but I've begun to see that it went a
good deal deeper than that Peters was
getting cooperation by proving that
there could be an unnoticed and
unnecessary leakage of manpower if
company officers didn't understand the
problem of combat anxiety in its many
and varied forms
now they are the many and varied forms I
didn't know then combat anxiety might
show up is it a sprained ankle it stayed
lame a well healed wound a pair of
broken glasses - faith
Peter's got right at the core of things
I told you business would be up tonight
the truth is many if not most of these
men wouldn't be here if we weren't
attacking in the morning their symptoms
are real but they're scared just plain
scared and most of them don't connect
their symptoms with being scared it's
normal
look I'll lead off and you can take home
when you feel like it huh
we'll do a doctor yeah lieutenant I've
sent this man in since he wants to see
you
his name's Johnson oh yeah what's the
trouble Johnson attacked the stomach's
all fouled up how does it bother you
it feels lousy all the time all the time
on and off for a couple of weeks just
sick when I wake up off my feet and
belching rotten eggs
quivery feeling all the time any pain no
man everyone out here starts belching
rotten eggs after a while it's a sign of
an old song put your head back
with that first sick call I started to
understand the various signs and
symptoms of anxiety that are common to
all men who have been in combat for any
length of time I was to find that there
were many men and officers whose
stomachs acted up for head headaches
palpitation loose bowels frequency airs
ability tremors or whatnot yet who were
completely effective in their jobs it's
not the symptom it's the man his
capacity for adapting to the stress of
combat
despite his anxiety nothing unusual
thought most of the men get the same
feeling from time to time you ever
played football yeah well you know the
feeling you get just before the game
this is the same thing only a hell of a
lot more so the corpsman will give you
something to ease the bouncing you'll be
okay hope so doc
what's his temperature normal doctor
doctor would you take a look at Jasper
down here had a headache the last few
weeks he says I'll go
this is a man doctor yes man you want me
to get your Thomas cope sir
yeah and then Jasper there was one
marine it seemed to know he was scared
and hoped his headache would somehow get
him off the lines I didn't realize that
at the time because in the beginning I
was inclined to spend too much time
trying to rule out unlikely organic
causes that's a luxury of civilian
practice later I'm afraid I may have
become a little too casual in a
diagnostic sense the best approach of
course is to take the man and his
complaint seriously whether psychogenic
or not and to conduct as sufficient of
physical examination this time permits
even if some conscious elaboration is
suspected it's not only good medical
practice but to do otherwise provides
the man with a convenient basis for his
resentments and a rationalization for
any reluctance to carry on you stand by
I'll be back in a minute
there that should fix it up thanks doc
say I've got a man here it says he's had
headaches for a couple of weeks I can't
find anything except a little nasal
congestion I think we ought to send him
back for some ENT steady what's his name
Jasper again huh Abel company let's see
if we can get some more dope on it we'll
give him a ring
Table six please
Table six let me talk to your company
commander
hello jack this is Peter's look Jack I
got one of your men down here name's
Jasper do you have any scoop on him yeah
I know him Pete a rabbit II sort of
character but kind of surly keeps to
himself sloppy with the details I think
he's a foul ball how long has he been
with you about ten days say look Jack
I've talked with this guy before he's
not a bad short basically among other
things have been worrying about home
matters he's new and he's not the sort
to adjust to a new crowd very quickly
give him a chance
how about getting sergeant grey to show
a little interest in him word from you
would help too oh brother
what's the Marine Corps coming to okay
okay send him back well do what we can
now cooperate for the work as before in
similar cases once a new man starts
feeling is a welcome member the
organization he doesn't feel so scared
and unhappy but you have to act before
the things out what do we do now give
him some explanation about these
headaches a few IPC's to take with him
and send him back to duty kindly but
firmly and don't get involved in any
arguments
what's up man then you got the pile doc
let's take a look
just a few tags we can fix that up for
you for the time being anyway I should
rather go to the hospital
hell no sir it ain't that bed I can't
leave the outfit now we're jumping off
in the morning can't you just put
something up there okay
the corpsman will give you something to
ease it that group spirit is the most
powerful support the doctor has in
keeping men at duty some men you just
can't evacuate even though you know it's
medically sound and some won't even turn
in when they should as long as the
Fighting's going on
well I guess that's all of them for sick
call this evening Korman will take care
of anything else that comes up I think
at the chief of let us know okay
we sure have a good bunch Carmen we do
that matter the aid man out with their
companies take care of most of sick all
right on the spot I expect they know how
to help with organic troubles but are
they have any value with these combat
fatigue cases all they sure are you take
those corpsman over there when they
report for duty I always give them a
briefing on the NP problem the necessity
for preventing the leakage of manpower
and at the same time spotting the
occasional anxiety cases becoming
useless in a danger to his outfit but it
just won't call it quits
above all I emphasize the company aid
man's great value in providing observant
information on all the referred cases to
help us make a fair decision about this
position you'll see what I mean in the
morning when the real show starts
softening up the division for jump-off
blow their shirts off this morning
sometimes
got about an hour before the casualties
start coming in time to wash and get
some breakfast see if I'll have things
set up in a few minutes
I think serious fella have to send you
to the rear for a while off okay sir
it'll need to sutures you can go back to
your outfit now
what's that [ __ ] we're dead grenades
landed right next to me didn't get you
Norbert a wing like the tomb sergeant
I started Holloman I guess I got excited
for a while but God God I don't know I I
guess I can take Carmen have a coffee
here
the man was alert responsive not unduly
exhausted the reaction was relatively
superficial and transient to evacuate
him to the rear might have sent up a
guilt reaction that he would have had to
justify by the development of further
symptoms he'd been thrown off balance by
a sudden shaking experience we gave him
a chance to get his bearings offered him
some firm reassurance and set him right
back
how about some water
smoke
thanks I just crapped out going up the
hill on attack been up all night
not all day on patrol yesterday I was
pooped scared like I never been before
even get my breath I guess I just passed
out I could just sleep I can't I doze
off like
and I jerk awake take it easy fella how
about rocking this man out near sick bay
I don't expect to move in the next 12
hours
what if he doesn't snap out of it by
then well we can always send him back a
regimental aid and have them hold him
for another 24 hours
we sent a note along indicating we
expect a man back shortly we've got a
good working relationship with regiment
on these cases they know how to handle
the occasional man we send them my
regiment
why not back to the division
psychiatrist well if you think there's a
chance for a fairly quick recovery you
should use the regimental aid station
one you can't hold the man here he gets
back on the job quicker still a part of
the fighting element of the division and
he doesn't get the feeling of being a
hospital case I see Peters was hitting
upon the basic principle of combat
psychiatry treat as far forward as
reasonable and return to duty as quickly
as possible in that way you don't lose
the great advantage of the man's
identification and pride in his own
fighting group and you minimize the
opportunity for symptoms to develop and
persist as unconscious justification for
escape now you take that boy looks much
worse than the others yet most of this
is due to physical exhaustion and lack
of sleep to factors which can often
mislead you into a bad prognosis
he's from Mabel company they've really
been kept jumping lately well give him
just enough sedation to knock out the
anxiety permit him to sleep that may do
the trick
doctor yours
tell me a flesh wound
what happened you son
grenade bounced off my helmet went off
knocked me dizzy you remember the sound
of the explosion your fly
yeah never forget it
I'm mr. hashed out right after headache
dizzy
some
let's have an otoscope blast concussion
it I don't think so but we'll see
that hurts your car
little it was not blast concussion I
gradually discovered that the familiar
symptoms of headache trans indigenous
and various acute anxiety manifestations
after a man had been shaken up by a
nearby explosion were usually best
understood and treated in Psychological
terms in most cases brain injury due to
concussion was minor or absent there was
no true retrograde amnesia no
hemorrhages no tympanic perforation no
neurological findings that hurt oh well
give him a mild sedative stat and get
regiment to keep him for a few days
before sending it back to his outfit we
can't keep him here because we might
have to move on nothing at all serious
fella nothing wrong with your head
you'll be ok in a few days but you do
need and deserve a couple of days of
rest and slate corpsman
this isn't a back to regimen Tony
well you look he going through the rear
and sleeping thus a cold day come on
bring your child to you boy that's for
me I won't have to do my own laundry and
are you [ __ ] all the breaks what is
your last name Decker first name
kill the bait
any spreaders no what's the story
corporal corporal do you hear me
what's the story
thumbs up damn good common we always get
useful information from him at some
coffee corporal
I left Oh God
you need a rest corporal will go back
but you need a rest crapped out set me
back send me back I don't belong here
I'm not sick need me go back with him in
a few days
Carmen get this man - meditite not much
left more than you might think I know
that man but out here for a long time
had just about all he can take a while
funny I always thought a man would be
glad to get out of this mess
not that one apparently that's just it I
can't keep it up any longer why they
feel guilty of letting their buddies
down all we can tell them what good guys
they are have it what do we do to treat
him well we reassure them as best we can
most of the men we see have these
feelings to some degree but in extreme
cases like that one way the get relief
business has to wait until it calm down
back at the medical company with
division psychiatrist Oh doctor we need
some help
I better do a cut-down I don't want to
waste time
that looks pretty clean ship them out
alright doctor
hey Doc my feet are killing me how long
since I've been here four months now
so you got a new pair of booth they give
you any support they did it first from
the pain came back let's have a look
pretty good-looking pair of dogs they
see but they hurt doc Oh
i fella what happened
let me have your wet good okay
sure come on let me have you away
we're going to send you to the rear
fella you need a rest maybe okay
certainly this man looked bad
yet not all such cases are irretrievably
lost even for further combat duty
although he had to be evacuated to
division there were some favorable
indications he had performed well before
his disturbed behavior was precipitated
by a sudden shocking experience he still
had a good fighting grip on his weapon
most shaken men are sent to duty by the
[ __ ] or the division psychiatrist but
there are a few who for the safety and
welfare of the group should never be
returned to a frontline unit the panic
prone the grossly immature the
profoundly apathetic the faltering
noncom who has lost the confidence of
his men
and severe hysterical reactions when not
precipitated by some sudden trauma hey
doctor
all right Tony you still here
disgusted zoo commanders outfit so it
stop was telling me last night
a bazooka man yes sir good the zoo
commands hard again
look I know your feet bother you but you
can carry on catching I don't know look
why don't you come and see me when we're
in reserve then we can get a specialist
to look at you
I don't think there's anything serious
stay loose okay sir
okay son we'll take that stitch out
tomorrow
sucks haters yeah three just called
we're moving up at 1800 search back safe
you honey you can catch your buddies
they need a man up there can handle a
bazooka
moving up at 1800 ya know
hey Tony come on
hi buddy let's go